نقلت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال الامريكيه عن
مسؤولين امريكيين واسرائيليين ان نحو 80%
من الانفاق تحت غزه لا تزال سليمه بعد
اسابيع من الجهود الاسرائيليه لتدميرها
وبحسب هؤلاء فان مياه البحر ادت الى تاكل
بعض الانفاق لكن الجهد العام لم يكن فعالا
كما كان يامل المسؤولون الاسرائيليون فقد
ادت الجدران والحواجز والدفاعات الاخرى
غير المتوقعه الى ابطاء او ايقاف تدفق
المياه وقال مسؤول امريكي لوول ستريت
جورنال ان اسرائيل قامت في وقت سابق من
هذا الشهر بتركيب مضخه واحده على الاقل في
مدينه خان يونس بجنوب غزه لتعطيل شبكه
الانفاق هناك وتشير الصحيفه الى ان
المضخات الاولى التي تم تركيبها داخل غزه
تستخدم المياه من البحر الابيض المتوسط في
حين ان المضخه الاحدث تسحب المياه من
اسرائيل وتشير ول ستريت الجورنال بحسب
مسؤولين امريكيين الى ان اسرائيل لديها
وحدات هندسيه متخصصه تضم مهندسين مدربين
على تدمير الانفاق وليس البحث عن من سمتهم
الصحيفه الرهائن وكبار قاده حماس وتذكر
وال ستريت جورنال ان اسرائيل بحاجه الى
مزيد من الوقت لتدمير
الانفاق